avec le développement de la plaisance de
plus en plus nombreux sont les
navigateurs plaisanciers véliplanchiste
qui empruntent la mer pour se livrer à
leur sport ou leurs loisirs favoris
qu'il s'agisse de la voile ou de la
pêche si la plupart d'entre eux prennent
toutes les précautions nécessaires nul
en revanche ne peut prévoir ou connaître
les mouvements d'humeur de la mer et on
est trop nombreux en tout cas sont
encore chaque année ce qui par
insouciance pour ne pas dire par
inconscience néglige les plus
élémentaires conseils de prudence et
s'embarque apport de matériel tout à
fait inadaptée pour méconnaissance
totale de la côte est des courants ainsi
en 1980 plus de 4200 bateaux et plus de
6000 personnes en détresse
ont-ils été assistés 616 autres
personnes dans le même temps ont été
sauvés d'un danger certain pour assurer
cette sécurité cette assistance des
dizaines de cas notes et de vedettes
sont prêts à tout instant à la moindre
alerte allait sillonner la mer mais des
centaines d'hommes aussi tous bénévoles
accepte par tous les temps d'aller
risquer leur vie pour porter secours
ce sont les sauveteurs en mer leur
compétence est le fruit d'un
entraînement assidu et rigoureux c'est à
cette action à la fois désintéressé et
efficace qu a voulu rendre hommage
le magazine qu'il aurait consacré cette
semaine
tu viens avec moi ou privés moi je fais
des morceaux dansants
[Musique]
sans nouvelles
depuis 6h un des verts en tête
la famille
est ce important non pas du tout au
large de courseulles qui sont engagés à
donner comme renseignements bon alors eh
bien avec avec le diable étant donnée la
marée l'écran sur le beurre une
direction dernière
plupart des gens croient que ratissant
sur une plage les postes de secours les
sauveteurs sont des fonctionnaires c'est
pas vrai ce sont des bénévoles des
privés qui font ça pour rendre service
ce qui entraîne que nous avons un
problème de finances la snsm est chargée
d'entretenir et de faire marcher une
flotte très importante
cinquante deux grands canaux 350 zodiac
et elle ne vit que de la des dons des
subventions des organisations locales
bien je vais vous donner lecture de
l'ordre du jour de cette séance du 12
mars
or ces sauveteurs réunis en assemblée
pour décider de l'organisation des
entraînements des sorties ou des
permanences la proche de l'été ne marque
pas une reprise des activités de
sauvetage simplement un nouveau rythme
d'une action permanente
ils sont agriculteurs commerçants
enseignants ou étudiants leur adhésion à
la société nationale de sauvetage en mer
est la conjonction de leur passion de la
mer et d'un certain sens de la
solidarité humaine avec une vedette avec
la vedette et asocial
je vous rappelle que pour assurer la
permanence que je distribue ses fins il
distribue aux pompes liés à ces musiques
métisses hydra héritière de la société
centrale de sauvetage des naufragés et
de la société des hospitaliers
sauveteurs bretons la snsm à la
responsabilité du sauvetage sur toute la
zone dite côtière qui s'étend des
confins de la zone des plages jusqu'à
l'horizon vue de terre et ce sur chacune
des façades maritimes de notre pays pour
accomplir sa mission il dispose de 50
canot tout temps capable de sortir par
les plus mauvaises mères oui de 84
vedette de première classe et diverses
et de 330 canot pneumatique équipés de
moteurs hors-bord de 20 à 40 chevaux
dans chaque département côtier certaines
stations sont permanents et équipés
alors de canot tout temps
ces deux vedettes de première classe
c'est le cas de ouistreham deauville et
courseulles dans le calvados
mais durant l'été c'est sur plus de 250
stations balnéaires dont 25 dans le
calvados et vingt-et-une dans la manche
que s'exerce la surveillance et
l'assistance de la snsm le
fonctionnement de la société nationale
de sauvetage en mer repose cependant sur
des moyens fort modeste et très
inférieures à l'ampleur de la tâche qui
lui incombe association reconnue
d'utilité publique
son action n'est soutenu que par des
subventions de l'état et des
collectivités villes et départements
augmenté de dons legs et cotisations
mais c'est en définitive essentiellement
au bénévolat de ses membres quel doigt
la réalité de son existence
nous ici de ceux ci étaient de sauvetage
nous avons comme politique pratique de
mettre des moyens à la disposition des
gens qui sont responsables
c'est à dire les zodiac et les
sauveteurs sur les plages de l'est
mettant à disposition des maires
les canaux comme celui ci nous les
mettons à disposition des affaires
maritimes et éventuellement s'il allait
chercher chercher quelqu'un très loin de
la défense nationale il ya par
conséquent des frontières et c'est là
que les choses deviennent
souvent délicate mais
l'avs la bonne entente de tous les gens
concernés qui est une bonne entente
générale fait qu' il n'y a à ma
connaissance depuis que je suis ici dans
le calvados
il n'y a jamais eu d'incident qu'ils
soient dus à un manque de coordination
entre les différents moyens en navire de
marins chevronnés pour les moyens de
haute mer sauveteurs qualifiés pour la
surveillance des plages
les bénévoles de la snsm n'en sont pas
moins astreint à un entraînement
régulier 12 centres de formation sont
ainsi répartis à travers la france dont
un dans le calvados à caen
les jeunes sont préparés au privé
national de sécurité et de sauvetage
aquatique indispensable pour être
surveillant de plage
à cela s'ajoute le permis à en mer
nécessaires pour la conduite d'engins de
plus de 10 chevaux ou le permis b pour
les patrons de vedettes les cours de
navigation parfois dispensés comme ici à
tout seul par un membre du centre
lui-même répondent à la préparation de
ces différents permis quant à
l'entraînement proprement dit il
consiste en des exercices en mer et en
piscine à raison d'une séance par
semaine
les sauveteurs s'exerce à toutes les
situations auxquelles ils peuvent être
confrontés ce que l'on ferait surtout on
vient régulièrement toutes les semaines
à la piscine de bayeux on s'entraîne
pour être surtout à l'est
décontracté dans l'eau parce que le
problème pour être sauveteur si on tombe
à l'eau c'est nous même d'être capable
de se sauver et sauver les autres races
qui compte sept à l'aise décontracté on
ne recherche pas là de la compétition
chez est conforme aux conditions et puis
dans un élément comme si c'était un peu
d'éléments naturels
c'est un effort de longue haleine et
répéter surtout surtout répéter
régulièrement toutes les semaines en
même temps ça nous sert un petit peu de
détente on en fait un plaisir mais ça
nous rend d'énormes services parce que
ben on n'est pas impressionné quand on
voit l'autre en ouvre ça devient naturel
sont saute à l'eau parce qu'on n'y pense
pas sur un travail d'endurance c'est à
dire qu'il faut nager une distance
importante dans des positions assez
facile la brasse on vient de le faire
c'est facile maintenant fait un petit
peu de crolles facile en souplesse toute
victime qui est inconsciente a
obligatoirement une obstruction tout ou
partielle de ces voies aériennes
supérieures aussi la première manoeuvre
et j'insiste bien là dessus consistera
dans le dégagement c'est à dire
l'aspiration des mucosités et
l'aspiration des rentrées de
vomissements pour ce faire vous avez
plusieurs techniques soient dernier
volet de la formation du sauveteur le
secourisme pour l'obtention du brevet il
est une des conditions essentielles avec
le permis à en mer et le brevet national
de surveillance et de sauvetage pour
être surveillant de plage pour être
patron de vedettes
il faudra satisfaire en outre permis b
et avoir été équipier un an auparavant
ou avoir déjà surveillé une plage
de façon à ce qu'elle arrive à la base
de la langue puisque c'est à la base de
la langue que ce constat nier je le
répète le sang les vomissements
l'accumulation de ces questions le type
d'intervention le plus fréquent
maintenant dans l'émission constance
actuelle c'est le dériveur ou la planche
à voile pendant l'été maintenant sur
toutes les plages il y a un nombre
important de petits bateaux ou même de
planche à voile qui s'aventurent en mer
avec des équipages qui ne sont pas
nécessairement très compétent et on ne
peut pas leur reprocher ils viennent
pour s'amuser le long de la plage ils
partent quand il fait beau et puis
s'aperçoivent sodas coca quelque chose
qui ne va pas et il appelle au secours
alors ça pendant toute la saison d'été
nous avons un ordre de grandeur de ici
ce dans le calvados de 300 350
interventions pour de ce genre
les sauveteurs assure la coordination
des opérations en mer relié par radio
avec la terre ils font régulièrement le
point sur l'état des recherches lorsque
le naufragé est repéré secouru il sera
si son état de santé l'exigent diriger
ensuite par les pompiers sur le samu à
l'hôpital le plus proche
si une telle assistance ne s'avère pas
indispensable là s'arrête aussi la
mission de ces derniers il appartient
alors au sol sauveteurs d'achever leur
mission
on assiste presque reprendre seul
non
[Musique]